hello and welcome to this video playing
room from lissa room Nyssa it's a funny
name somehow I don't know what it means
but it sounds sounds funny okay i'm
doing a bit of one year for again
looking for some variety so I don't want
1 p-5 to happen that quickly so go here
for and I'm going for an F for expansion
aha so let's go a form before he goes 96
Wow
oh it's not a move that I expected but
it's in fact more than likely that he
knows this position better than I do ok
let's go to age 5 I mean that's not
great for my structure but at least he's
not so easily getting the night to g6
it's not quite clear where his King is
going i mean my king also doesn't have
natural squares i can only say wow again
ok it's true ok winter it's a very very
drastic decision very interesting ok
that's pushed e5 that that gives lots of
space and ask this night a couple of
inconvenient questions
you see canceling long I guess years huh
c5 looks like the only move here anyway
but I'm not quite sure what i'm doing
after that see 595 doesn't lead to much
I guess
it looks pretty nice isn't it doesn't it
check and threatening kingham rupee one
now okay maybe you just count now I
cannot castle hmm
some c5 business now my king is not
exactly safe either wow I'm not seeing
any museum Bishop situ Wow ok
and maybe I could have played rookie won
by the way I played that too quickly
here rookie one was interesting hmm now
I was been probably not only interesting
but also good okay but here I'm taking
no let's check come on concentrate let's
focus as I've it here you can play a
rare count to check only see that in
movies check into answered with check
now I came didn't listen it didn't
happen Jeff let's take him and now what
now maybe just Tiki and go to g1 I mean
the should I strongly check on on his
king my king is still relatively safe he
has no yeah I know important attacking
pieces
let's let's assume Bishop h7 what am i
doing then probably just take on c6 King
takes Queen d5 should win that I should
win actually quite quickly check check
check
check okay i can check here and rookie 7
but check that also should do the trick
let's see 95 is it a shake on the form
it's a bit annoying so let's go here 27
mate it's difficult to prevent yeah that
one but
pony I'm not doing this very efficiently
my king is still quite safe he doesn't
have a any meaningful threats
checkmate yeah oh he completely
surprised me with the ton of his moves 9
g5 was very strong medicine here she
fired and gown and I'm not even sure all
night a try but I felt that limiting his
night should be worth something a dad
sits in all together wacky position I
don't I cannot really say what this okay
this is it seems that seems very risky
yeah the engine wants to castle that
gives widen almost winning advantage
that's pretty imprint this line now it
looks terrible i had that night if he
cancels long i have Luke invasions now
it looks bad but that isn't bad either
right yeah 1.7 also good and here
Queenie r3 was already winning double
threatening yeah f5 and c6 okay check
and that this oh yeah I could have
played see 50 his son
messaging me quickly yes c5 that's a
good move that's a good more something
like that isn't clear I can check it
goes here here and he's on this way and
clear really unclear engine gives equal
aquinnah three was a lot better but this
is probably not so great I could have
played rupee one yeah I was too quick
with Queen d2 rookie one was good
something like this this and I'm I'm
winning a piece at the end check well
what am i winning I've got two or two
bishops for Luke it's pretty good yeah
and I was a bit too quick but yeah I'm
channeling now right you know this is
this is check this is a winning position
chan black has no defense now against
that Bishop takes his six idea check no
Chan Ho be miss Chen braids check
Queenie eight well I missed chemist 95
yeah that was that was the best check
here this is Jason's was saddest best
way to do it check shouldn't be any
check me any way out here okay thanks
for watching